well i'll be honest with you guys well
look a second ago
uh susan was talking about comfort and
she wasn't that comfortable with acting
as much as
the voice over and doing all that the
voice and and i thought the first thing
i thought was
comfort i don't think i've been
comfortable doing anything in my life
i'm always
uncomfortable i mean do you guys have
you guys always been confident what
makes you nervous
what makes you well stop maria what
makes you nervous do you get nervous
when you're acting do you get nervous
before are you pretty
i only get nervous if i don't feel
prepared
uh if i'm prepared then i'm excited
definitely a similar physical reality
and that the heartbeat fact
is beating fast um but different
mentally if you're prepared it's
exciting that makes sense
yeah yeah phil um can you hear me yeah
yeah
what a dick no um i'm same with maria
i don't get nervous anymore
unless i'm doing something i haven't
done before
or that i'm unp that i feel like oh gosh
i should know this better i should um
lat two winters ago i did
my first musical um
at the pasadena civic auditorium like a
big musical with like real dancers and
everything
and honestly that was probably the first
time i was like
nervous in about 20 years what happens
when you're nervous is it something you
could deal with or is it something that
was overwhelming and it was
in your thoughts all the time during
that process it's um
it's it's funneled you know i i remember
the very first time i went on stage
in eighth grade just walking out on
stage
opening the play with a monologue and
you feel the energy of the audience
hits you and i think for some people
that can be overwhelming and like it's
like being electrically shocked
and for some people it's empowering
it's like these people are mine i'm
stealing their souls and it makes me
large
[Laughter]
carl told me a story when he first you
know got into performing and that was
a bizarre which which is so funny to
think of you
being unprepared being you know not a
natural
yes i i no i was not a nun i was a
writer and i
essentially um i was a journalist i was
assigned a story to cover this
theater improvisational comedy theater
that had lost their cast
to l.a and they had a public audition
with a couple hundred people
i ended up going there to cover the
story it was handed an audition card
and thought well this will be perfect
i'll write this story from the
standpoint of someone
who desperately wants to be a part of
this company
and then has to watch us other more
talented
people are picked and so it was
over about a month period on the
weekends and they kept winnowing it down
and um in each iteration
of um letting people go i
was i remained and there were probably a
number of factors for that this was in
minneapolis i
i may have been the only black actor uh
black person who
was in this process anyway it ended up
being
uh whittled down to five people i was
one of the five people
uh then i told them no i'm not
attributed to this
i wrote this story i showed you the
story and i said so give it to
you know it should go to someone who
wants it and then i
i forgot it and then they called me back
and said
would you be interested in
considering being part of the company
you wouldn't you
carl are you saying that you wouldn't be
an actor if it wasn't for that
absolutely i would not be an actor what
was the company carl
it was dudley riggs brave new workshop
in minneapolis minnesota
and it was kind of the fellow who had
been del close's partner
in um second city had split off and
carl do you believe in the hand of fate
do you think
obviously right that's the only way i
think it could have happened
and then of course certain things
because in that instance it was
sort of like riding on your feet and you
also needed other people
and i am a fairly private person
but i really loved um that collegial
feeling
and that's part of what i
i love about doing this work is that
in a way you're doing it by yourself but
you're it's always collegial it's always
either in concert with a writer and a
director or in concert with
other people you're working with and um
in
these instances i feel like an extrovert
because i want to bring
my best to the table and what's make
what makes me nervous
is when i feel certain about what i'm
doing
or going to do wait what makes you
nervous is when you feel certain that's
when you get nervous yeah
yes yes i like i like that
i like the feeling of um i used to play
basketball in college and if
before a game i didn't feel slightly
nauseous
i always wondered
what was going on and generally in the
middle of that wonder
i would begin to feel slightly nauseous
and then i'd be fine because
i think beyond that uncertainty is the
only
thing you can count on in um in life
and um it's it's certainly well in and
out of my professional life
you know things happen that you just
didn't see coming
and um you you roll with it you
um so yeah this was not what i had
planned wow